I I don't know you've probably talked
about this ad nauseam but I was also
fascinated with the fact that you know
you you dealt a couple of years ago with
the fact was it your brother who was
your uh
um accountant yeah I can't really talk
about it because I'm doing a documentary
on it now but it's yeah
oh you don't want to go there no okay we
won't yeah I had to put my brother in
prison uh it was pretty pretty brutal
okay but I don't want to get into that
today I want to keep it keep it lighter
because I'm excited about the show no I
will always talk about the show but I'm
fascinated by people who have such a and
and this is my you know my uh whole
um coping you know I deal with you don't
know me that well personally but I deal
with a lot of stress and a lot of mental
health and a lot of [ __ ] and I'm
fascinated how people you've gone
through it and those are really
traumatic
things to and and I think the
cataclysmic moments actually form your
true character and so when I look back
in hindsight at some of the things like
that
um I wouldn't change a single thing
because I actually really I re I mean
that you know that that Billy Joel went
through kind of the same thing I think
that was his brother's law yeah that was
his brother-in-law who rendered him you
know destitute he had to go out on he
had to go out on tour and I'm always I
was pretty destitute but I would imagine
besides being destitute financially
those kind of uh trust issues you know
never lost trust in people really no
when somebody who is your flesh and
blood they're a sociopath a sociopath if
you know anything about sociopaths and
you know I know way too much at this
point you know it's it's not all people
I know you don't want to talk about it
I'm not asking to talk about but I
understand everybody wants to talk about
it's fascinating it's really my own
personal Dateline uh story and I live
the center of it but also
in the documentary so tell me about the
documentary there is a documentary
coming out in the fall yeah we're gonna
we're doing a documentary about like
kind of like that period of my life and
what was it are you in the midst of
shooting it now yeah yeah we're shooting
it and are you shooting it for a special
uh is there or are you gonna shoot it
and then sell it or okay yeah yeah I
love that and you're producing it that's
right are you directing it no
are you um is everybody being
cooperative
so far so good
okay yeah is is he still in prison no
do you speak to him no
is he part of the documentary I love
that you you're like we're not gonna
talk about it we're not going to talk
about it
I don't mind this is like this is like a
little hype it's like no no it's good
because I don't mind talking about The
Fringe because the reality is
this this
unbelievable moment in at the upper
echelon of my comedy career I'm the king
of the comedy World in that in that
moment and the darkest thing is
happening to me simultaneously it's
literally comedy and tragedy and when it
all kind of fell apart or now look at it
fell together it's fascinating and even
though it's my story and yes it it hurt
and it was the ultimate betrayal who I
became from it I'm so I'm grateful that
it happened I would not change a single
thing it was meant to be
do you think he learned anything I don't
know love to see when we watch the
documentary I really want to see the
document I want to see a special I want
to watch the moment
[Music]